all right amber
hey welcome back again hi thank you for
having me so you had a rough ride
this year you got beaten up not long ago
yeah i did a few months ago um yeah
things have changed a lot you know um i
have a couple friends that are saying to
me
what's wrong with you you're not the
same
so i started thinking about that like
what's wrong with me i'm not the same
so then i have to start asking that
frightful question
like am i different because what
happened have i been different since
what happened to me
and they're like ah yeah
you are as matter of fact it is about
say when that [ __ ] happened to you
man i went to the police station and i
walked into the thing
and from the beginning the desk i used
to call them the desktop
totally act like i was bothering him
like
from the beginning when i said i'm here
to make a report because i was assaulted
it was like oh here we go with another
one of these again like it was
everything was a problem
and i was hurting physically and
mentally you know
and i was like wow i haven't even got
behind the door yet
and i'm already being she's like crap
so i was waiting i think i waited about
an hour and a half
waiting for someone to talk to me just
to at least take down
what happened the the memory i did have
of it left
um i don't have i went back up there
like you know
hey what's up oh you're still here
all right let me see if there's someone
that can help you i said oh no
it's okay have a great day
i walked out and said hey you're getting
that face looked at
and i started crying
that's [ __ ] that one you get that face
looked at
and and when i at night sometimes
when i go to sleep that's the only thing
i keep hearing keep that face looked at
like i'm not studying beauty or anything
i'm not going to knock myself down but
i'm not going to
put myself up there like you know the
most people when it works they're
beautiful but having the broken teeth
and the scars it's got a discovery
there's the teeth
that's got to be hard the fact that
i used to be able to get not say any guy
but i used to have a problem catching a
date
now i'm i'm i'm begging with the the
beggars i'm
i've had to go way low on my price
i do all kinds of things to try to hide
my flaws
then now i'm just like this is what it
is take a yes or no you know
take it if you want it not thank you
really hard because i'm feeling it
um it also makes people think that
you're
a doormat that they can do the same
thing to you
or that they can um abuse you or assault
you or
and i had someone tell me
you think that guy flicked your face up
i'll [ __ ] your face up
and i'm like how much more can you do
to it like it's like you know
like nine nine things i could i can find
this wrong with it
and that hurts
however a lot of people had great
comments and
words of encouragement and show awesome
compassion
and i just want them to see that i'm not
dead
i'm still here but
i'm broken without a doubt however
what was me remember i said that a long
time ago i never signed up for this [ __ ]
so sometimes i get my dark moments
and i'm like i never signed up for this
i never asked for all these problems i
never asked for
any of the things that have happened to
me
i just want to look out for my sister i
just want to
take care of her
never knew that making that decision was
gonna make my whole life
suck tell me about your sister
she's she's wonderful she's a republican
she's um has a business
she's a polar opposite of me completely
opposite thank you
i mean i love her so much
and she hates me just ain't me
because she didn't know me we weren't
raised together she hates
what i represent or what i am
she ate you know so she turned
republican
she is against drugs she's against
people on welfare services
i call it you think i'm always in space
and she says no you're not
but i'll be there i'll be this as long
as she
has what she has the nice cars nice ever
you know she's the mother opposite she's
just she's awesome
and um but damn i didn't think that you
know making that decision was just gonna
be
like so life-changing so i hate that
[ __ ]
to call to turn my mom into my family to
to seek for help to
do whatever it took to make sure that my
sister were running that
apartment with those no lights no gas no
food i mean maybe i
think of it like maybe i could have went
to this entity or this service or
maybe this relative or maybe i could go
to my dad's side of the family instead
of my mom's it's always what if you know
i really try to put my chin up and you
know take it on they say
what makes you like what makes you cry
it'll make you laugh you know
and i can laugh about my sister i love
her so much
it's okay maybe one day she'll come down
here and you can meet her she's an
awesome person
and i look at her and i think all the
things i could have been i should be
but and i still could be but i don't
want to
i don't got anything no more i don't
want to go to school
why i don't want to be seen you're going
to go to school now nothing nothing
i'm doing nothing but feeling sorry for
myself and i know
it's fresh it just happened but
with everything going on in in the world
right now is not the time to really be
feeling sorry for yourself
but and you're still working
i have to i have to but i
do i did say yesterday i saw an awesome
commercial
with one of the um i don't know if i
could say
amazon dealer i want to try to get a job
there for holidays i know there's
massive hiring
try at least try something
i'm but no i'm not working i'm still
working not going to school
you've been working the streets for how
long 10 years
hard heavy 10 years and looking back
what
what do you think of that decision that
you made
still work on the streets just be out
here doing this
at first it was the right thing to do
it's it has me it did everything for me
but i didn't know i didn't know anything
about the business or i'd have no
pimp i had one friend who turned me out
when i was a kid and
like i said i'm richard i'm looking for
my richard gere and i'm julie roberts
so i've always thought about i've always
been on the fairy tale side of it so do
you think girls
are looking for some guy to save them a
savior
yes everything's called captain sabo
yeah
that's a common thing yeah everyone's
yes they might not admit it but they are
because
who wants to be doing this when they're
like 70 years old 60 years old
you want to find someone i want to find
somebody who's going to be like
my district gear and it's going to make
it make everything all my problems go
away and help me
just help me make everything easier and
from the girls perspective
is that a real relationship or is it
just an arrangement that
provides security and and gives them
what they need
there it becomes or is it both it
because they can be both it could be all
three
yeah you have an arrangement yeah yeah
it's all
it's always this blurred line right it's
all all three
me i'm getting i'm getting to the point
where i'll just
like i'll take anybody you can be old
you'll be young you could be a girl
you've been in love before
uh a lot yeah i'm currently in i thought
i was in love right now
since i was in love but i don't really
know what love is
the examples i've had have been
important samples
so i know what the definition of the
word is
i believe that i'm in love but at the
end of the day
love wouldn't do the things that it does
to me or
so i don't know maybe not do you feel
like you love yourself
then someone told me that like they said
you can't let me until you love yourself
and i'm like what do you mean what does
love yourself be
what does that mean to love yourself
means to be able to
accept all the good things that life has
to offer
in a relationship that would mean to be
able to accept a partner
who's kind supportive patient
someone who's fully invested in helping
you to fulfill your dreams
that's like that that's like that
cinderella um who's charming
maybe from the world you come from it
seems like a cinderella thing but yeah
so let's get that someone visits all
those those things
it's almost like love needs to be this
almost impossible
situation where both partners believe
they're
lucky to have the other person in their
lives at the same
oh i time to believe that i'm lucky to
have you
in my life and you need to secretly
believe
that you're lucky that i'm in your life
and that has to coexist
so when that's out of balance and it
starts straining one person gets bored
no i don't and and yeah it falls apart
and it's a constantly changing dynamic
where one person
you know gets older one person gets
depressed right no i can't say i mean i
i love myself
i can say that i love myself enough to
put on clothes
i love myself enough to strive to work
on living every day
that's the kind of love i have for
myself i love myself enough to live
you know be the best way or the best
life but
i think i love myself enough to live
because i wake up every morning like
oh thank you lord thank you for waking
me up even if it's
to deal with that worst day ever thank
you
my mom passed away in her sleep so i
hold on dear waking up
i think that's why i don't like to go
sleep much either though you know but
hey it's inevitable
um i don't know
mark things have changed i just i didn't
want to
next time you saw me i'd be um in a
middle institution or missing arm or leg
and not know what happened in that gap
of time you know i just want to
stay relevant and stay
somebody out there cares because i've
seen them the numbers know
is this your lowest point
yeah no my lowest point was when i lost
my children
so this is right around there they're
fighting
and you have how many kids i have four
children and they're with who now
not really sure i know that my oldest is
with his dad
and the last three are hopefully they're
all together
in a foster room together or something
cause that's twins
then a year later had another baby and
um
they were all taken by state and me and
my issues i didn't
i messed my twins up visiting my
children
my twins visiting them i gave them a
an anxiety condition where they worry
about
if their parents they're with is going
to leave them
so i made a decision with my last child
jacob
not to be a part of his life
not to put myself there and then have to
disappear not to
put myself in a situation where i
pretend like i'm okay i do everything
they tell me to do the classes
the everything it takes to get your
children back and then a year later i
mess up and they go to all
different places and have to experience
that
separation anxiety all over again so i
try to ease their
pain i believe probably wrong but this
is how this i hold on to
i believe that me not being around and
me not being in
is is is gonna eliminate some of the
separation anxiety
i'm all screwed up i know sorry if you
could put your finger on one thing
that set your life down this path
what would you say that was
the one thing i know
not telling not knowing that you're
supposed to tell
someone when you're being touched or or
bothered by an adult
by an adult that one thing because i
took that permission
that sexual inside just got as a small
child
it stayed with me it just matured you
know
i looked at porn play by magazines
i was very curious about sex and sexual
things
and i did a lot of secret things like i
would play with
little boys in the closets and stuff
stuff like that things that probably
all stem from me being touched as a
child
it goes both ways doesn't it for for
some women they close off to sexuality
and
because i was thinking about the other
day i was talking someone about it
and i was saying how my molester was my
first love
my first love really i was in love with
someone at the age of four years old
i had to be around that person cried
when i couldn't be with them
um devastating when my mom stopped
sitting and start stopping me to the
to be babysat depressed because i lost
my
first love at in the first grade
first started talking about running away
and hurting myself in first grade
because the one person that played with
me all the time that was my
best friend she's my best friend was
also the one that hurt me into touching
me
and what i was in love with i think
that's love
even at six years old when he wasn't
around
i cried and i was sad and i mourned as a
child
that's heavy i know my life gets heavier
but i don't know what do you think you
struggle with most is it uh anxiety
depression anger
awesome depression because everything
needs to cry
everything's sad can never see well that
can never
i don't see the good stuff about things
first i've always noticed the sad stuff
the dark gloomy stuff first you know
and does the shame guilt from your
situation with your kids does that
get to you guilt that guilt
um so there's depression
and there's guilt
the guilt the mother's skill is so huge
i'm saying for me i don't know about any
other parent
any other mother out there but
my mother's kill is huge because
look i have babies out there and i don't
know where they are i think about them
every day
all the time and i don't have a clue
i put them in harm's way by not getting
them back
so i pray and like that they'll turn up
be like me
that that that hopefully i put hopefully
i broke the cycle
in my family does that deal with my
until my mom did
she's doing what her parents did you
know i'm hoping that with them being
away
i broke this cycle that they won't see
the lifestyle
or the experience of my lifestyle
but then other times i'm just like
what if they call out with me at night
what if they call for me at night what
if someone's hurting them
and then you hear all these horror
stories about department of children's
family services
like how they're just awful
and um the guilt so i'm not gonna feel
anything i'm gonna go out and go
score that for at least this hour i'm
not gonna be thinking about
them it makes you feel it i don't feel
you don't you don't feel yeah that feel
button is doesn't exist it all
disappears
oh there's no feeling not
nothing these scars my children
i'm just high it's all okay oh okay
i was like i'm taking this i'm cheating
i'm taking the easy way out
and that's when i get depressed it's not
just the drugs
it's it's real you know the depression
is real it's real because sometimes i
get
it gets so dark that
i don't i don't want to i don't want to
wake up
i don't want to wake up [ __ ] it
it's no still now i'm done
but i'm not going to do myself i'm
looking through myself
but not luckily i'm not going to do it
myself because i think that my religious
to do with that
and so a lot of these guys they're
they're pimping but they're doing
they're what they call a boyfriend
they're the boyfriend you know the girls
don't know that they're being
pimped they really think that that's
their boyfriend and this is just what
he's allowed them to
her to do you know but actually he's
pimping his whole conversation when
she's not around is about pimping
and how he's pimping her and stuff like
that or his friends know or you know
that's the worst part it's the kind that
play you like you're their girlfriend
and you fall all in love with them and
then it comes out it turns out that they
are um
pimp you or accepting your money like as
they use
your money right yeah managing my money
or accepting my money like i owe you
this
it's interesting how a lot of the older
girls have told me that uh when they
finally got out got away from their
their pimp they
i asked them if they kept any of the
money or they saved any money and
the answer is always no oh no like when
they like if they separate from him
yeah somehow oh you're very lucky if you
get the clothes on your back that's what
i'm saying
it's just a bad situation you've been
doing this for a while
do you know anyone who's done this and
and gotten out
unscathed they they saved money and
bought a house
sometimes i haven't met anyone they
actually saved money
oh no not even because you literally
give all your money to this person but
but even without a pimp
i mean no for instance me i'm
like a perfect example if i left i would
be
i'm battered and bruised yeah i guess
inside outside yeah
yeah so yeah definitely no one gets out
of here
not even the guy the street life is
addicting isn't it
oh it's very it's like a drug it's like
a drug it's like a drug
you you want it you desire it and
your brain tells you you need it just
like drugs
just like a drug so it seems the sexual
abuse that happens in childhood
leads to drug use which leads to sex
work
which leads to losing your children on
you
it leads to depression and and just
endless
chain of destruction you know if that
sexual abuse had never occurred
the trajectory of your life would have
been very different that trauma never
occurred
a lot would be different a lot would be
different
um it's that one thing this probably the
trauma can't occur but if you fix it
with you know with help psychiatric help
or you know or
awareness of the parent knowing or
whatever what's going on if it's fixable
if you fix it
they can or she can get through it
live survive so she survived that trauma
but if you don't
fix it then that trauma sits there and
the trauma goes on top of there
on top of that and you end up uh having
children and
knowing where they are and on the
streets so
10 years later there's a lot of things
about this lifestyle that that are
problematic
but one of the things that that really
gets to me after hearing all these
stories
is how there's no one in your life
who cares for you who truly cares for
you i mean the from
from the tricks to the temps to the
other girls on the street to the cops
like nobody
everyone's on the take everyone's got
their own best interest
and and and you're just something to be
used and thrown away
and that must be a really lonely way to
go through life well yeah it's probably
one of the worst ways to go through life
yeah
not mattering but knowing that and you
know you don't have anyone well if you
know that you
if you know that then you are a little
bit better than the person who has no
clue
still living in a fog that these people
care about them but
like they're called throwaways that's
what i'm trying to remind people they
just want your money or your body
that's that's what they're gonna get rid
of you they want users they want this
they want that you could use your arm
yeah
definitely they use you up so you kill
yourself
or end up in some jail forever or
something
we talked last week about you getting
depressed sometimes
do you ever get suicidal yeah i have
gotten suicidal several times you know
but
um i know religion and in my religion
it's the biggest no-no and
thankfully that's the one thing that's
kept me alive
because when i'm in my darkest moment
you cannot tell me at that time that
anything's gonna be better
it's the end of the world for me and was
it was sitting in the world for me well
let me just go ahead and just
do what i need to do but my religion has
kept me alive because
i know that it's like it's a big no-no
you can't do it i'll drive down figueroa
some nights and i'll i'll just i want to
rent a school bus
and and pick up all the girls and and
save them
and only are they savable some of them
don't want to be saved so
some of them this is what they believe
or they
know that this is their calling david i
think you know
tell me if this makes sense to you it's
almost like
i mean very very often they're stories
of sexual abuse in childhood
and we all try to recreate those
childhood relationships in one way or
another
but that's what we all do the
significant relationships of our
childhood
we tend to recreate as adults and it's
the only thing that we'll accept as an
adult
some form of that not better not
different
in this life is a very good replacement
for that abuse that a lot of the girls
had as
as children having guys that will just
do whatever they want with you
disrespect you and throw you away and
you become used to that and that becomes
your normal
and you don't understand even if
something better came along
you'd find some way to reject it and you
only want that and this lifestyle
supplies that
and anything else is is of no interest
right you don't recognize
the good in anything because you're just
used to and
something good came along right you
would miss it you'd reject it i'd miss
him i would miss him
because i think he's some lame loser
some lame person
well i mean you think he's you wouldn't
trust him if richard gear came into my
life i wouldn't believe it
because why me like how how like
how did i get chosen but even if somehow
he broke through and you guys got into a
relationship
i would ruin the relationship you'd ruin
the relationship because i'm not that's
not my normal
i'm not used to that i can't appreciate
this glass of wine that's exactly right
there's no appreciation for it i'm glad
you said that
what would you say to a young girl young
woman who's uh considering this
this career well considering this
lifestyle is a
got to think about you got to see
everything the good and the bad like of
course you get money
but can you imagine sleeping with
say eight guys a day 365 days a year
do that math and you're literally
putting your body through
that trauma um you're going to be
traumatizing yourself
you get to a point where it becomes so
addicting it's like you have to go to
like a
aaa meeting a fellowship a meeting to
figure out
how to live with that craving that
desire that allergy
and um i would just suggest that you
just
don't do it don't do it like there's
other ways to make money
especially right now with technology and
things going the way they are you can
make better money faster
with less risk because it's risk you're
gonna risk your life
you're gonna see your insanity you're
gonna your family everything is so risky
imagine like okay today i'm safe i have
a
beautiful face i'm normal and then in
two hours later i'm beat to a pulp
that's the risk you take and then you
think that this person
your boyfriend or your man or your your
people your folks
you think that they care about you that
they'll patch you up they'll bring you
up
they might just give you a band-aid and
just send you right back out there
or they might just throw you away you're
no good to them
right because everyone's not made to be
rich everyone's not supposed to be rich
but i would rather have my mental okay
and be poor or be without the
money that i'm getting out i have a lot
of very wealthy friends
and they're more miserable than a lot of
the people i
interviewed in applications or in south
central right those people are happy or
on skid row
happiness is key but to the young ladies
or the young men that are thinking about
getting into this profession because
they can get it like that or you know
they'll have nice things
those things so there's looks so the
beauty
so who scans fades sags just don't do it
i'm not really sure how to tell someone
not to do it because i was never told
how not to do it
i get to share my experiences and my
life experiences and what i go through
every day and what i'm going through now
as a guide
so this is what can happen this follow
this road this is what's going to happen
you're going to get hurt you're going to
it's just numbers
mathematically this is it has to happen
all right amber thank you so much for
talking with me again thank you so much
for having me this is great
all right guys thank you
you